I am going to make a fact statement  Greta tunberg's group violently attacked  journalists  is it is it confirmed that they're all  in the same group were they just all  their kind of disportedly Desperately  what does that even mean like they were  all there of their own volition didn't  know each other but some people were  violent some other people there there's  one group and protesting  climate stuff  well let's let's watch the video what  game I'm not going to play  is that these these leftists have long  done this where they quote unquote  respect A diversity of tactics and then  they'll they they will all feign uh  ignorance and reject responsibility for  what they organize which is violent  attacks on journalists it happens all  the time and then you'll get an  organization and it'll be called like  you know save the planet  and then when antifa shows up and gets  violent they go oh well that was us yes  they are otherwise you'd kick them out